Schalk: Okay, cool.
Anyway, welcome.
Sorry we have
a slightly late start.
We're actually attempting
something that I think is
quite aggressive.
So we have a star-studded panel
here.
Let me introduce myself
very quickly,
and then I'm gonna hand the mic
down to our panelists here
and just do some quick
introductions.
And then I have
a few intro slides,
and then we'll get into
a bunch of demos, okay?
So my name is Chris Schalk.
I'm a Google developer
advocate.
And, essentially, I work
with OpenSocial.
And because my past is a bit
of an Enterprise past,
I have a special feeling
for those out
in the Enterprise community.
And I've been having numerous
discussions with these guys
for a long time now
on how we can, essentially,
make OpenSocial work
in the Enterprise.
And so that's, essentially,
the goal of this talk.
So let me go ahead
and hand the microphone over
to our star-studded panel here,
and they can introduce
themselves.
Carroll: Hi, my name is
Dave Carroll.
I'm a technical evangelist
for salesforce.com.
Mayerhofer: Hi, I'm
John Mayerhofer,
and I run the business
standards team at SAP.
Grall: I'm Tug Grall,
and I'm responsible
for the product strategy
on eXo Platform.
Brookes:
Mike Cannon Brookes.
I'm the co-founder
and co-CEO of Atlassian.
Manalang: Rich Manalang,
and I work for Oracle.
I'm part of the product
strategy team in Oracle
that looks after
social networking.
Weitzel: Mark Weitzel,
from IBM.
Part of the emerging
standing team at IBM.
Schalk: And you can hold onto
the mic, I think, for now.
So anyway,
before we get started,
also, we do have
a Google moderator page.
The URL is actually quite long,
so I created a bit.ly URL.
so bit.ly/enterpriseopensocial.
So feel free.
Toss out any questions
you think are relevant.
And we'll be spending
a considerable amount of time
in the second half
of our presentation
just, you know,
working with your questions.
Okay?
Now, as I mentioned before,
that's our agenda.
It's fairly straightforward.
I'm gonna provide
a very quick overview
for any people who are new
to OpenSocial.
I just want to make sure that
everyone's kind of
on the same page.
Actually, a real quick show
of hands.
How many people are not really
familiar with OpenSocial yet?
Okay, so that's good.
I'm at least providing you
a bit of a starting point.
Okay...so let's just jump
right into it.
What is OpenSocial?
Well, it's essentially a set
of APIs that allow you
to build social applications.
And these APIs are standard.
So what that means is that
it's not one company or,
you know, one particular
technology.
These standards have been
brought together
by a set of companies
that have been collaborating.
And they've been working,
essentially, since...
almost, like, two years now.
So very quickly, what are
the benefits of OpenSocial?
Well, as you can see here,
before OpenSocial,
if you wanted to build
an application
that had social features,
and you wanted to take
your application
and put it into
different networks,
it was a bit of a challenge.
You really couldn't do that.
So as you can see here, our
Joe Developer is not too happy.
But now, with OpenSocial,
that was launched back in 2007,
there's, essentially,
a set of standards
for building
social applications.
And these standards revolve
around three core areas.
So friends, profiles,
activities.
And so, basically, once these
standards have been launched,
this allows for
standardization
of social application
development
across any, what we refer to
as container sites,
or Enterprise companies, for
that matter,
that have the ability to,
you know, adopt these standards.
Then they can essentially run
the same applications
and the same technology.
So this guy's much happier.
I should also say
who owns OpenSocial?
Is it Google?
Do you guys think that's true?
You may think so,
but it's not.
It's actually run by
the OpenSocial organization.
And true, Google did
kind of spearhead
these initial set of standards
early off.
Google did donate
a substantial amount of code,
especially when you get into,
like, Gadget, and so forth.
Gadget Rendering
and things like that.
But it's now essentially managed
under the auspices
of the OpenSocial Foundation.
So if you really want
to have, like,
a high-level starting point
to learn about OpenSocial,
you can just go to
www.opensocial.org.
And from then on
you can start to get
a nice, high-level view
of what exactly OpenSocial is.
Who's using it?
Well, we have, like,
a number of partners.
We have millions of end users
around the world globally.
I've been personally involved
in reaching out
to a lot of different companies
in India and Japan and Korea.
And to be honest, it's been
a real pleasurable experience.
Just to be able to share
this technology
and the adoption rate
with our partners
is quite substantial.
And they really jump on
to the technology.
This is a latest-number chart
that basically shows, you know,
over 800 million end users
are now being able to use
OpenSocial technology
in a number of different
web sites and--
Well, we refer to them
as container sites.
So just to kind of give you
an idea of the breadth,
or the overall volume
of the OpenSocial users
is quite substantial.
The overall volume of
OpenSocial developers, globally,
is also in the thousands
as well.
So it's serious technology.
I don't want to take up
too much time,
but a few main points.
It was launched
back in 2007.
We very quickly evolved
from version 0.5, 6, 7.
We had some new containers
launched, like MySpace, hi5
early in the day.
And then, I think, another thing
that I'd like to point out
on this slide is that
version 0.8, last year,
that came out came with
essentially restful APIs.
So what that actually did is
that opened up the door
to other service site
entities
to allow for two-way
communication.
So essentially, transfer
of social data became possible.
And that is, essentially,
one of the key things
that a lot of our Enterprise
partners are looking to
take advantage of.
And here we are--
we've already passed
our one-year milestone.
We have, you know,
well over 600 now.
And we're now looking
at 0.9 now
as the current version
of the API.
So why are we doing
this session?
Because personally I feel,
and all of my partners feel
it's too important to ignore
the Enterprise
when you're referring
to social technology.
So we feel that the core
concepts of people collaboration
is vitally important.
And by using standard
technologies,
we all feel very strongly
that there is a justification
for exploring this area.
Are we there yet?
Not yet.
We're still working.
There's a lot of prototypes.
A lot of cool technology.
But do people equally--
Do people, like, equate
OpenSocial and Enterprise today?
I wouldn't say that yet.
But that's hopefully what we're
trying to do is kick this off.
Hopefully get some buzz started
and see what you guys think.
So basically,
we want to educate, brainstorm,
and share what we have today.
So with that, I'm gonna
go ahead and kinda jump into--
'cause I want to make sure
we have enough time--
is to our first set
of demos.
And so I believe
we have Mark Weitzel,
who's gonna come up and show us
what IBM has got in the works.
I'll just...
Oh, the switch.
And on number one, right?
Are you on four?
Weitzel: Four.
Schalk: Okay.
Weitzel: Thank you.
One of the things
that I'm gonna show now is
some work that we're doing
as part of my team
in the emerging standards--
the emerging technology group.
I've got a pretty good gig
because I get to play around
with a lot of the things
that are forthcoming.
I get to work with
our product teams.
And early on, IBM has been
looking at mashup technology--
situational-app technology
for a while.
And we have a number of products
that deal with
this kind of mashups,
and also collaboration.
And so OpenSocial, as we start
to get involved in this,
is very interesting to IBM
for a number of those reasons.
What I'll be showing today
is some early
proof of concept-type work
that we're doing
with one of our Lotus teams.
The Lotus Mashup Maker team.
And I'll show what we have here
here is...not that.
Now, let's see here.
Schalk: You'll have to go easy
on us
because we have a fairly
elaborate setup.
Weitzel: No, I need this icon
that got moved around.
Uh, everything is small.
So this is our
IBM Mashup Center.
And one of the things that we've
been doing inside of IBM
is working with Gadgets
and Widgets for a while.
Unfortunately, at this time
they're not OpenSocial gadgets.
We have a specification that
we've been working on internally
because we've been doing this
for a number of years.
And we've been working also
with an open foundation--
the OpenAJAX Foundation--
trying to get metadata
and Widget/Gadget technology
interoperable.
So what I'm actually gonna
show here is a demo
of our Mashup Center.
Schalk: You want me to hold
the mic?
Weitzel: No, I got it.
Schalk: Okay.
Weitzel: And the sizing might be
a little off here,
but what we'll look at is--
this is our Mashup Center.
And we've created
a little bit
of a very straightforward demo
that talks about
how you can assemble
these Mashup pages.
And one of the things
that we can do
inside of our Mashup product
is eventing back and forth,
like you can do in OpenSocial.
We externalize those
to have wiring
that you can use declaratively
in things like Tools,
which we think is
an important way
to get consumability.
So I have
a very simple demo here,
where you can take
a random number
and you can publish it.
But I can go into this page,
into edit mode...here,
and I can then drop down
and select, maybe...
maybe not...
some OpenSocial gadgets.
Now you gotta hold the mic.
Schalk: Here you go.
Weitzel: Let me see
what I can do here.
Let's see...
Schalk: That's the one.
Weitzel: Yeah.
I'm gonna have to get this here.
Oh...well...
Looks like I lost my, uh...
Looks like we might need
to go to plan "B" here.
That should not be there.
Here we go.
There we go, all right.
So now I've got the OpenSocial.
Where'd that guy go?
So there's one of my OpenSocial
widgets that I've grabbed
that will do the subscription.
And I'll grab another one here
that will do the publish.
And I can just drag those on.
And I can resize these
and move 'em around.
So now when I don something
like a subscribe here,
I can publish this.
This is being published
from an OpenSocial gadget.
And this is being published
from one of our internal gadgets
using technology from OpenAJAX
called the OpenAJAX hub.
We can talk more about that,
maybe, in the Q&A.
The important thing from us is
this gives us a way
to take some of our existing
work that we've done,
some of our existing products,
and start to bring some
of the OpenSocial technologies
into these things
and have them coexist
peacefully together.
And it also allows
the consumers
to be able to easily
bring these things together
and create these pages.
The last thing that
we want to look at is--
I talked a little bit about
the eventing here.
This is being able to read
some of the externalized events
in the metadata
that's available
in something like
an OpenAJAX widget.
And one of the things
that we're interested in is
if we're gonna do these complex,
consumable mashups,
we'd like to have
the same kinds of things
in OpenSocial.
And you can see now
that we don't have that.
So the kind of extensions
to externalize that information
is one of the things we're
interested in
working together on
and finding out
from the rest of the group here
what sorts of things
they'd like to see.
So with that being
seven minutes into it,
I'll turn it over to, uh...
Schalk: Well, thank you
very much, Mark.
Weitzel: Sure.
Schalk: Yeah, we're definitely
looking forward to seeing
what more innovations that
you guys are coming up with.
So anyway, thanks a lot, Mark.
Weitzel: Okay.
Schalk: Come on up.
Rich, from Oracle,
is gonna show us
a cool demo as well.
Manalang: Hello.
Schalk: What number again?
Oh, you're number two.
Manalang: Two. Okay.
So I'm gonna go through
a real fast speed demo here.
Schalk: And if you have
questions about each demo,
feel free to enter 'em
in the moderator page as well.
We can--We could take it
at that point.
So go for it.
Manalang: So the history
behind Oracle
and its involvement in...
...internal social network
within Oracle
just as kind of a Skunk Works
kind of development effort
to try and test out some of
the interesting things happening
with things like Facebook
and MySpace,
and bringing it into a firewall.
So we built this thing
called Connect--Oracle Connect.
And basically it's a--
This is basically, I think,
the fourth revision--
fourth version.
And we have an Oracle person
out here--Oliver--
that's taking pictures
and posting them onto Connect
as we talk here.
But basically it's a...
If you can think of, uh...
man: I have a job.
Manalang: If you can think of,
you know,
Facebook and Twitter
and all the things
that are happening
on the public web these days,
and kind of mash it up
and try and figure out
how that works...
Um, and mash that up...
And what we've done is
we've kind of taken
all those pieces--
all the interesting pieces--
and built a tool that would
allow people to share things
inside Oracle.
So here's what it is.
Basically you have the ability
to do things
like post your status on Note,
which is similar to a blog.
Link--share links, ideas,
questions, and media,
and also code.
So you know, code is for
our developers
who want to be able to, like,
share code out there
that's similar to just posting
some piece of source code,
and have people comment on it
and things.
You have different views,
like a network activity
or a group activity
and all the activity.
You can comment.
You can like something.
You can, you know, just go
through what people are doing.
It's kind of a stream
of what's going on at Oracle.
As well we have
a profile system
that allows you--
It's kind of like
a company directory as well.
So if you take Facebook--
the elements of Facebook--
where you can look
at someone's profile
and see the information--
phone numbers and things.
It's the same kind of thing.
You can see a hierarchy.
You can see how far down
I am from Larry Ellison.
You can see a bio and, you know,
my status
and groups I belong to
and tags.
And then we also introduce
the notion of
what we call "Kudos."
It's our version of the "Wall"
on Facebook.
It's much more focused,
and our use cases for
all the times when you had to
send out an email
to someone you worked with,
or their manager,
to say thank you for, you know,
doing a great job
on this particular project.
So Kudos has been
a great little widget
for us to be able to
put inside Connect
to encourage people
to thank each other
for doing good work.
And you can also see
people's network--
who they're networked with,
contact information,
and location.
So in terms of posting,
it's interesting.
People can post
different types of things,
like media.
Um, there are some videos
in here, I think, that--
We actually have a nice
filtering mechanism--
dynamic filtering mechanism,
so we can filter things
like source--where it came from.
You know, we can sort by,
you know,
what type of activity it is.
If it's a status,
a question, an idea
from a particular time period.
It's sorted in different ways,
by freshness, popularity,
whether it's recently active.
So some of the things
people use to post--
Like, there's people in here
posting things about Wave.
There's video
that people have posted.
So it's similar to, like,
a Twitter experience,
but you can post
whatever you want.
And the other aspect of this
is, you can imagine,
you know, at Oracle, there's
80,000, 90,000 employees
posting in this one system.
And this activity stream is
just flooded with stuff.
So there's a way
to scope that down.
So we've introduced
a thing called Groups,
which allows you to go in
and basically look at things
in a much more focused--
And you can invite people.
You can create public groups,
private groups.
And you have, basically,
the same kind of feature set
as the public piece of it,
but it's much more focused.
And so we have lots of teams
in Groups within Oracle
that are actually using
this tool
as a communication
productivity tool
within their teams.
You can do feeds
and things like that too.
In terms of OpenSocial and
the way we started interacting
with OpenSocial, um,
when we created this--
You know, our team consists
of four people,
and there's two of us
that code this.
And so, you know,
when we first launched this,
there was a lot of excitement
toward being able--
people being able
to contribute to it.
Everyone has an idea, right?
And there's tons of developers
at Oracle
who want to participate and
build something on top of it.
So we were thinking of ways
to be able to scale the ability
to contribute to their project,
and, you know, short of, like,
giving people commit rights
to the code.
So at the same time,
around 2007,
that's when OpenSocial was
announced,
and we were thinking
this is a great project
because then we can just,
you know--
here's a framework
we can introduce
that's got an API,
it's all fully documented.
We can introduce this as a way
for people to build applications
on top of the platform
that we've built,
uh, without us having to
have to do that ourselves.
And so we got involved
and contacted Chris.
Chris actually used to work
at Oracle as well.
And, you know,
looked at the ability to--
to use OpenSocial
within Connect.
So what we've done is we've--
Right now we have the ability
to say, like, add a gadget--
an OpenSocial gadget
on people's profiles.
So, like, on your profile
you can go in and, say--
I have this one OpenSocial app
that I created called Tag Buzz.
And I'll add that to my profile.
I'm being told
I'm out of time here,
so I'll show you this
real quick.
So Tag Buzz is basically--
It goes through and looks at
your user profile tags
that you've tagged yourself
with.
And within there it'll
basically go out
and search Twitter for things.
I used to work
on the PeopleSoft product,
and one of the things
I used to work on
was PeopleTools.
And I can say what people
are saying about PeopleTools,
and I can reply directly.
So that's initially what we were
trying to do with OpenSocial.
Schalk: Great. And I know
you have the Gadgets,
but you also have Shindig
and stuff also running.
Manalang:
Yeah, we're using Shindig.
We've got an app directory.
And the code is JRuby on Rails,
but you know, Shindig is running
as a separate part of it,
and acting as a container.
Schalk: Okay, well,
thank you very much, Rich.
All righty.
[applause]
Yeah, feel free to clap.
I mean--
Unfortunately,
we don't have steps.
Who do we have next?
Uh, yes. Go ahead.
We have John Mayerhofer
of SAP.
Mayerhofer:
Computer number three, please.
man: Yeah, and if you could
turn on the microphone.
Mayerhofer: No,
I've got a mic.
'Cause I noticed your arm
getting tired.
Schalk: Okay.
Mayerhofer: So...
Okay, so again,
I'm John Mayerhofer,
and I lead the business
standards team at SAP.
And I want to say thank you
to all of you
who must be highly interested
in this topic,
as opposed to going to lunch.
That's a true show
of interest.
And so I hope we can,
as a panel,
not disappoint you here.
I'm gonna just give you
a few words on who SAP is
as context for why we care
about OpenSocial.
So SAP is focused
on business applications.
We are the number one
business applications provider
in the world.
Our customers represent
the output of about
50% of the world's
gross domestic product.
So we have a pretty big
footprint.
I'd say, more importantly,
we touch the lives
of everyone in this room.
So we help power 75%
of the world's beer production.
We help power 65% of the world's
chocolate production.
If you guys have bought a song
on iTunes recently,
you touch an SAP system.
Because we sell things
that are from the core,
like General Ledger,
Human Capital Management,
Master Data Management, to
Business Intelligence Software,
we touch everything.
Because we do that,
we have a great opportunity
to bake in processes,
and to enable processes
that help our customers run
more sustainable businesses.
And that's a great opportunity
and a responsibility
that we take very seriously.
So why do we care about
OpenSocial?
Well, we enable business
processes--
software business applications,
model and enable business
processes
which power business networks.
Business networks consists
of people in other entities.
The relationship between people
has been important in business
since the beginning of time.
Many of the business processes
that we enable
can benefit greatly
by providing the full benefit
of those relationships
between people.
And the relationships between
people and other entities,
like the processes themselves,
or companies or groups,
for example.
So this is why we care
about OpenSocial.
I'm gonna show you, briefly,
one component--
one tiny component of SAP
Social Composite.
This is not actually
a product yet,
although it's being used
internally
by our employees at SAP.
It's called the
Relationship Analysis Server.
The Relationship Analysis Server
enables you to gather in data
from multiple sources.
It could be an exchange server,
for example.
It could be an HR system
or a CRM system
or many other sources.
And it enables you to define
and divine the relationships
between these entities.
This thing is accessible
via a RESTful API.
Any of you guys can
download this server
and write apps against it,
by the way,
and I'll show you where
to do that in just a moment.
And we've written an app
against it
called the Social Network
Analyzer.
And I'm gonna go and change
my identity for this demo.
So I'm no longer
John Mayerhofer of SAP.
I am now Nicholas Cox,
a collections manager
in a mid-size software company.
And what you see here is
how to access
the Social Network Analyzer
if you want to download it
or play with it online.
This sample data
that I'm about to show you
is accessible on demand.
So feel free to go here
afterwards.
This site, by the way, is
our equivalent of Google Labs.
So this is our kind of
labs area
for business intelligence
software.
So in the course
of my job--
in the flow,
in the context of my job
as a collections agent,
I get an invoice.
I try to collect
on this invoice.
For some reason,
it's overdue.
In this case, Calex,
the customer--
They're a big customer.
They're a good customer.
They usually pay on time.
There's something wrong.
But for the last three weeks,
they haven't been returning
my phone calls.
And so I want to use
the relationship--
or the Social Network Analyzer
here,
which can be in the flow
of my SAP system
to do my job and collect
on this invoice.
What you see here
on the right-- this view--
is the profile panel.
Nicholas Cox is the user.
And Nicholas' profile
is aggregated
from multiple systems.
In this case, an HR system
and a Project system.
In the middle is
the entity pane.
These are all the entities
that Nicholas has access to.
And on the left you see
a search bar
in faceted browsing,
using the two in conjunction
to get to where you want to go.
So if I click on one of
Nicholas' profile elements--
Palo Alto--
I will see all the people,
or all the entities,
that are associated
with Palo Alto.
33 out of 63.
If I want to see all developers
in Palo Alto...I can do that.
But back to my job--
collecting on this invoice.
So I'm gonna search on Calex.
Yep, Ursula Nobel is the contact
from Calex.
A lot of her profile
comes from our CRM system.
I'm going to explore
Ursula's connections
to my company.
So I see here there's multiple
different types
of relationships.
You can define "relationship"
such as "is a member of."
In this case we're looking at
"is a member of" types
of relationships.
And Ursula is a member
of these groups.
We could also have--instead of
the Ursula Nobel entity,
we could also have
the entity Apple,
and show the connections
to all the products
that Apple has bought
from our company, for example.
In this case, though,
this is good enough.
Ursula Nobel is a member
of multiple groups.
So likely, if I go
to the connect tab,
it's gonna be easy to calculate
the shortest path to Ursula.
This is what it's all about is
the shortest path to Ursula,
who is not paying
her invoice.
So I, Nicholas Cox,
am related to Ursula
through three or four steps.
The relationships are: I report
to Marge Collins, the CFO.
Marge is a member of
the sales steering committee.
And Ursula is also a member
of the sales steering committee.
So Marge, and executive,
sits together with Ursula.
The odds are if I throw both
Marge and Ursula on a clipboard,
and initiate an action
to both of them--
So here it says "send email."
I could easily say
initiate conference call
or initiate an Adobe Connect
session.
It could be trigger an alert
to an ERP system.
Anyway, I click on that,
I get an email triggered
to both these people.
And now Ursula's bound
to get back to me
because she doesn't want
to embarrass herself
in front of her executive friend
on the sales steering committee.
This app also runs
on an iPhone.
And I'm told by
our business innovation people
that it will be running
on an Android system
in the not-too-distant future.
So this is just on small aspect
of what we're doing
to work in the social component
of business,
and enable the social component
with the best available
technology.
So SAP and OpenSocial...
SAP is a supporter.
We believe that the concepts
behind OpenSocial
are going to make the lives
of our customers better.
We believe that the standard
is viable--
it's, you know,
out of the gate.
And we would like
to work together
the colleagues here
on this panel,
as well as other Enterprise
companies
and the broader
OpenSocial community
to help modify and evolve
the standard
so that it actually meets
the needs
of Enterprise customers.
And it's a pretty big
population
with a pretty big impact.
So, if you have any questions,
I think I'm done for now.
Schalk: We can hear
the questions at the end.
But anyway,
thank you very much.
Mayerhofer: Thank you.
Schalk: Who do we have next?
[applause]
We have Dave.
So hopefully we'll have
enough time
for the panel discussion
as well.
Do you want me to hold the mic,
or do you want to do it--
Carroll: Yeah, you can hold
the mic for me.
Schalk: Okay.
Do you still have to plug in?
Carroll: No, no, I just have
to cheat and get a URL.
Schalk: Okay, okay.
Carroll: I need my glasses.
I didn't need my glasses
when I first started
in this industry.
So salesforce.com...
we have historically looked
to the consumer web--sorry--
the consumer web...
to give us direction
for the business web.
And like we've seen,
internet applications,
business applications,
Enterprise applications
go onto the web
in terms of sass and on-demand.
Rich UIs, some of the
UI paradigms
that you're used to seeing.
We're also seeing, now, Social
as another thing
that we need to make sure
that the people
who are using the internet
can use it in the business
scenario.
And Social's a big part
of that.
To start,
what I'd like to do--
I'll hold it for now--
--not that I don't
appreciate that--
is start off with a couple
of customers of ours
who are currently
taking advantage of
the social web today
on our platform.
So what you see here is a site--
a live site at a Starbucks
called "My Ideas."
And this is a site that
they built
on the first dot com platform
that is used to reach out
to their customer base
to enable Starbucks
to better listen
to what their customers want,
and react with that.
But there's more to it
than that.
So this application
is not only available
right here on their web site,
but is available on Facebook
as an application.
And so people that come
to this site from Facebook,
when they vote for an idea,
when they suggest an idea,
of course, that's updated
on their activity stream
so other people can see it.
That way Facebook--
sorry, Starbucks has
this viral exposure
to a lot more people
than those who might wander by
and see their site.
Which I think is a big part
of Social on the Enterprise.
Dell, another large company--
Enterprise-class company--
building a social application
on the force.com platform.
This one is aimed towards
innovation, as you can see.
And I know we're
running low on time,
so I'll go to one more site,
which really has a kind
of two-edged social--
social networking as well as
social awareness.
This is a site
by Starbucks again,
built on the force.com
platform
to get people to volunteer
for charity events.
And so salesforce.com's approach
to OpenSocial, in particular,
is to create a platform
on which you can build
these applications,
connect to various
social sites.
And in that way bring
the social aspect--
the professional networking
and social networking--
to the Enterprise.
Now, I have a demo,
and Lord willing, it'll work.
So if you'll hold the microphone
for me...
I just have to type in
a correct URL.
Okay, so it's gonna be:
61demo-developeraddition.
na6.force.com
[laughter]
Now you know why I had to look
at my cheat sheet.
So you know, the force.com
platform allows you
to exercise various kinds
of APIs.
In particular, REST APIs are
very easy on the platform.
And what I've done here
is built a site
using a developer edition,
which anybody can use today.
Oh, by the way, security is
a very big, important thing
for Enterprise customers.
And that's why I'm willing
to put up with
the mixed security message
there.
And what I've got is
kind of a customer portal site
where my customers who--
they may be at arms' reach
from me,
but they still want
to let me know about
maybe some support issues
that they have--
can come here and,
rather than create
yet another set
of password credentials,
they can just sign on
with Google Connect.
Of course, Google Connect
leverages the OpenSocial APIs
and specifications,
so I can go ahead and select
maybe my Google account.
Sign in as a different user
here...'cause that wasn't me.
Schalk: Oh, right.
[laughter]
Carroll: And see, this is coming
from Google,
so it's not just my site.
Okay, so once I sign in there...
then I can automatically
be signed in as a user
inside of this new portal
that I've created for my site.
And this is something
that our customers can do.
And so once I'm signed in,
of course,
I have access now
to a "cases" tab,
where I can see various cases
that other people
have published.
I can submit my own
support case.
I get things like--
interesting information,
such as profile pictures.
But more than that,
I also magically get
some social networking
capabilities
without actually having to
implement them on my platform.
Because I'm allowing Friend
Connect now to keep track of
a lot of the activity
that's happening on this site.
For instance, we have
an activity stream.
This can be on a per-page basis,
or you can submit an ID,
so maybe the activity's related
to a specific case.
I can also see--whoops.
I can also jump into comments
about a particular use--
er, uh...support case that
somebody might have filed.
They can give us answers
and so on.
And so in this way
we allow our customers
and our developers who are
building applications
to connect to the various
social networks.
And so I'm a little under time,
and I'm gonna leave it at that
and turn it over
to the next person.
Schalk: Okay, thank you
very much, Rich--uh...Dave!
I was looking at Rich
when I said that.
Anyway, so next up we have Tug,
from eXo Platform.
And thank you very much
for coming.
Are you all set?
Or good afternoon,
actually.
Grall: I want to start
with a very short one slide
to show you at least--
If you don't know
what eXo Platform is...
Schalk: Is that microphone on?
Okay, okay.
Grall: We are an integrated
portal.
We develop data for contact
management, collaboration,
knowledge management,
discussion forums, calendars,
this kind of stuff that use
and are based
on a standard-based portal
on all the sub-layer standards
in the Java world.
So portlets, Java Content
Repository to manage content,
but also for RESTful,
based on AJAX--
or REST--REST services.
And we have added OpenSocial
to be able to communicate
and create social applications
between all these components.
And we [indistinct]
and we leveraged
the security model
and the storage that is already
in eXo Platform.
So when you arrive
in your portal--
I will authenticate...
And depending of my profile,
I will see, more or less,
more information.
And using OpenSocial,
you can create your friend
contact clusters.
You can remove or add.
But also we do mashups
of two portlets.
So it's not kept yet
in this specific page.
It's two standard-based portlets
that use OpenSocial as a beacon
to aggregate the list
of my profile of my friends,
but also some Google Maps
information.
So it's not only able
to share information
between multiple consumer
services,
but also internal applications,
such as the Content Management
System,
will be able to provide
information on the platform
using Activity Stream
to the different contacts.
So what I will do--
I am connecting
my operating system
to the Content Management
System.
[indistinct]
So now I can surf
my Content Management space
on Java Content Repository.
So it's based on the pure
Java-based standards.
I'm taking one content
from my local drive
and push it on the server.
So now it's stored,
it's secure,
and it could be shared
between different users.
And if I go on "Chris...
activities..."
I can see now that
one new activity
has been added
to the stream.
And I can also see that,
on my dashboard.
And here we are moving
to the gadgets.
So I show you more of
the server side of OpenSocial,
where now I can see
the client side using gadgets.
So we see this new activity
streaming.
And they are purely
OpenSocial gadgets running,
for most of them,
inside eXo Container.
But this one is coming,
for example,
from [indistinct].
And what we have here is
we have multiple gadgets.
One, the list of my documents.
And I will show you how we built
this specific gadget,
and how you can
administrate that.
So I will go to my, let's say,
back office.
But, in fact,
it's the web OS.
So the web overriding system.
It's a new way of using
the application
directly from your browser.
So what I have here is
I have a portlet.
But this portlet,
instead of being
on the standard portal page,
it's directly in
my multi-window system
inside my browser.
And what we see is it's
a total base portlet.
Another way of using the gadget
on top of desk port desk.
And this specific portlet is
where I administrate and create
and deploy portlets and gadgets.
So for portlets,
you deploy your [indistinct].
You deploy your
standard applications.
You can do the same
with Gadget.
But we have, also, something
that is quite interesting,
if you want to be able
to make your platform
richer and richer,
is we can directly edit
new gadget
directly from the browser.
Or use WebDash to push
the XML file.
So here is an OpenSocial gadget
that is stored inside eXo.
And one important part
when you deploy
for the Enterprise,
it's about how you expose
these gadgets or portlets
to the user
based on their profile.
So when I choose to expose
a specific gadget,
for example this one,
I can choose who will
be able to use it,
who will be able to put that
on his dashboard.
So I show you, like,
how I can create the gadget.
But how I created the backend--
the REST services--
so you can use any REST API
of Java API.
But what we also have
extended is--
We create, using Groovy
as our scripting language--
an editor that you can
directly use from your browser.
So I am using, again,
the Java Content Repository
because, you see that here,
I have the content
with the newer command.
But I can also directly edit
my Groovy card
inside the browser.
And for people that are familiar
with REST services--
REST uses, Java based--
we use a connection to GSR,
and I can deploy and update
the service as I need
when I am running
in production also.
And since we can access Gadgets
using WebDash,
you can also plug that
to your IED
to be able to put that
in the most standard life cycle
of that kind of the allotment.
Schalk: Okay, well,
thank you very much.
We're gonna go ahead
and switch over now to Mike.
I can hold the mic.
Thank you.
And again, feel free
to submit your questions
to the moderator page
that we have.
And hopefully we'll have
some time
to have a good discussion
afterwards.
So I'll go ahead and
hold the mic for you as well.
Feel free to introduce yourself
again as well.
Brookes: Uh...
Schalk: Oh, you zoomed in.
Yeah, there you go.
Brookes: All right, I'll try
and do it briefly,
and I'll try and use some--
oh, jeez.
That's gonna make life
interesting, isn't it?
All right, well, sorry.
I'm using someone else's machine
with a PDF
that didn't come across
properly.
Um...
Schalk: Do you want to switch
to one of the other machines?
Brookes: No, that's all right.
Schalk: Okay.
I can hold the mic.
Brookes: [muttering]
All right, so how many people
know who Atlassian is, or...
Excellent. More people
than OpenSocial.
I love that.
Thank you.
So we make collaboration tools
and development tools.
Our collaboration tools,
obviously,
large enterprise wikis,
et cetera.
Um, the, uh--
There we go.
Well, you'll just have
to scan through this.
I apologize.
Schalk: I'll pull it down.
Brookes: So one of the things
I wanted to talk today about
was the development tools--
so something a little bit
different.
Collaboration tools, obviously,
are wiki.
You have friends and other
people,
so it can be implemented
as a social network
relatively easily.
But I wanted to talk about
development tools
and how we're trying to make
them also into a social network.
So if you think about developers
very quickly,
they're people who work
in teams,
collaborate on some sort
of shared objects,
and they generate
a whole lot of activity, right?
So if we have a look
at who they are, briefly...
Down here you can see
the shared objects they work on:
obviously source code,
issues, builds, projects.
Some sort of documentation,
specs.
These things, as developers,
we're all used to.
And the activity they generate,
obviously things like Commits,
build values,
comments, new tasks, new issues,
that sort of thing.
So we thought it'd be
really interesting
if we take all of this activity
in these shared objects
and try to put them into
some sort of a social context
using OpenSocial.
So the other part for us
that's important is--
this slide
in the bottom left-hand corner--
is today, pretty much
all your Enterprise apps
are basically silos.
So we also look at OpenSocial,
besides being a social
technology ,
as a very interesting
technology stack
for connecting a lot
of Enterprise applications
in a very, very simple,
standard way.
So in this case,
your applications--
In this case, one application
might be your source code for,
looking again
at the developer network--
your issues, tasks, projects.
And let's assume you store
your documentation
in some sort of wiki.
These are all, at the moment,
relatively disconnected.
So what we can see is
with OpenSocial,
we can do some things where
we can actually connect
all of the applications
together,
so we can put pieces of the wiki
into the issue tracker.
Or pieces of source code,
for example,
into the issue tracker.
And then we can do things like
get a complete view
of your project.
So instead of just seeing
the tasks,
and then moving to another
server to see the source code,
we can start integrating all of
these different things together
so you get a single activity
stream across everything.
No matter which set of tools
you're using,
you can comment, interact,
and things like that.
And another scenario I'm going
to show you very briefly
is "managers."
So let's assume the developer
on your development team
works inside JIRA,
or some other issue tracker
as their center point.
Most managers spend
a lot of time doing email.
Most of their time, all their
time doing their work email.
So Gmail actually gives us
a really nice,
open social container
to start pulling
various development tools into
that the manager might want
to look at
in order to see
what's going on--
viewing activity status
and creating issues
and that sort of thing--
during their development
management.
So we've launched this site.
If you want to get more detail,
there's a whole bunch of movies,
screen shots, and other stuff
at atlassian.com/opensocial.
If you want to find out about
OpenSocial in the Enterprise,
it's a good place
to have a look.
So let me give you the briefest
of brief demos.
So this is JIRA 4,
which is in beta, as of Monday,
running with a whole bunch
of different things inside it.
So for those familiar
with JIRA,
you'll be relatively familiar
with things like these charts.
What you want to be
familiar with is that
you can now, obviously,
move them around
into a whole bunch of things.
Everything you see on this page
is an OpenSocial application
or a gadget.
So they're all running here.
The different colors I've used
in this case to connote
that these things come from
Confluence.
So I can do nav against
Confluence,
and go and navigate
to my wiki pages.
Similarly, I can see
my code reviews.
And these gadgets themselves
are, obviously,
just standard OpenSocial clocks
and weather widgets
and that sort of thing.
And things like the build data
I can get here,
so I can see when
the build is failing.
It'll refresh itself.
So one's failing,
one's passing.
So this is the sort of thing
you can get.
And similarly,
like everyone else,
we have a directory.
But remember, these are all
development tools,
and all the tools
I'm interacting with here
are for developers.
So if you want to get charts,
you can here.
See, I can get charts
for my build system,
charts for my issues--
go and get them from Source
Control, that sort of thing.
So, trying to bring all your
development tools together.
And obviously, because
it's an open standard,
XML based, other development
tools can implement gadgets,
and we can pull them in as well.
And all of this, uh--
If I had more time I could show
you this entire dashboard
running in iGoogle.
So if you have JIRA running
publicly,
we support OAUTH
and everything else.
And because these are
all gadgets,
you can them pull them out,
and put them into a different
portal container the same way.
So more interesting here--
ooh.
Let me sign out of Dave's email.
Sorry.
If we think about the job
of a manager--
So in this case we've created
a fake Google mail account.
I apologize to Google for using
some of your resources--
of pseudo-development manager.
Schalk: We do the same thing.
Brookes: Everyone has multiple
Gmail accounts.
It's allowed, right?
So this pseudo-development
manager has
a development environment--
sorry, an email environment
that actually involves a whole
bunch of different gadgets.
So for those that don't know,
Gmail is actually
an entire sort of
social container.
You can put gadgets into it,
you have lists of friends,
you can make a network.
So if you're using, for example,
Google Enterprise apps,
you can have all
of your colleagues in there,
and then you can create
social groups
in apps for the Enterprise,
or whatever the code name is.
But what you'll start to see
is things like--
You know, for example,
this is a developer.
Obviously Mark's a little lazy
'cause he's just emailed me
and said, you know,
here's a bug.
Which doesn't really help me.
But what I can now do is,
inside Gmail,
I can actually create the issue
from inside here.
And I can obviously go
and create it.
It's gonna create it in JIRA
in here.
I have the issue--
I can go and look at it,
or I can just email him back
and say, "Here's the issue."
We can pull in
all sorts of gadgets.
So we have your social network
from Confluence coming in.
That's the sort of standard
Facebook-like
social network, if you like.
You can see, you can mash it up
with Twitter and other things.
And then this is
a particular gadget here
that shows you--
This gadget here is
actually running
with the social data
from Gmail.
So I have Jonathan and Tim
actually added as friends.
So I will only see
their activity
in this particular gadget
in Gmail.
It uses a Canvas View,
so it'll open up...
It would show me Jonathan's
activity if I logged in there.
But the interesting thing,
I always think,
is you can sort of chat
over the top.
So I can have all these
different services
running in Gmail.
And if I had more time,
and Wave was public,
I would give you a demo of
the same thing running in Wave.
Schalk: The paper that you
just des--or the URL.
The new web site
that you launched,
it gives details
on this thing--
Brookes: Yes, there's movies
of this in much more detail--
atlassian.com/opensocial.
And you'll be able to download
the JIRA container for Monday.
Thank you.
Schalk: Well, anyway,
we're getting towards the end.
Thank you very much.
Awesome demos.
[applause]
I am going to shift us over
into Q&A.
And we have moderator questions,
but feel free to come up
to the front here.
We're obviously running out
of time.
Our timer says that we have
seven and a half minutes,